[Music]
we all know that the kovat 19 pandemic
has caused the temporary closure of so
many businesses those who do qualify for
unemployment I've stated it's not enough
so what are people doing to offset the
cost of living during this time hey
everybody my name is Maya Dora I'm a 26
year old youth living in sunny Los
Angeles and I'm here to tell you a
little bit about how I've been staying
sane productive and making a little bit
of money while during this whole
quarantine hey guys my name is Dana
Lynch ah I am 26 years old from
Cleveland Ohio hello my name is Richard
B and I've been a end up comedian for 18
years my name is Chris trovador I am a
professional tattoo artist I've been
tattooing for 10 years I'm Kelsey rose
and I look as a food stylist and as the
shaft hi my name is Sarah and I live in
Los Angeles
I work as a Japanese freelance
translator
[Music]
prior to the outbreak I was working in a
dental office on the weekdays and a yoga
studio on the weekends since the
outbreak has happened and we have these
orders from you know the government I
haven't been able to go to work both of
my employers have shut down both the
dental office and the yoga studio and
have offered to or at least suggested
that we go on unemployment prior to the
kernel virus outbreak I was a product
specialist for auto shows now because of
the virus that has been on a halt
because you cannot be in groups larger
than oh now 10 so these events probably
won't happen till later fall or until
things get better I have lost all of my
gigs for the year of 2020 one of my
biggest gigs I have for the year was the
Tokyo Olympics and the Paralympics I've
been dreaming of this job since I was a
young kid and it's unfortunate that it
has been postponed I work freelance in
the words my father if you know you eat
what you kill right so if I don't work I
don't get paid and it started right when
like we were really getting coverage
about what was going on in Wuhan and
then the case is in the United States
were starting to pop up my boyfriend and
I like I will admit dismissed it you
know I was like this is probably another
flu outbreak you know it happens you
hear it on the news
bla bla bla it wasn't until like I was
booked out for the rest of March which
was secured income I was super good to
go great clients and they all just
started either pushing the dates or
canceling them completely and the worst
thing I like was reading was like we're
gonna push indefinitely the way this all
came down for me was this way I flew in
from what the malla my tour had just
started as I flying from what Amala I
started hearing on the news that Kovac
19 Carano virus was planted in China
I really didn't it didn't constrain me I
really didn't pay any attention to it
I was so focused on continuing this tour
I had two shows coming up had my
birthday's on the 22nd we had multiple
shows during the week as as the week
went on they first announced and said
hey you might have to reduce the show in
terms of capacity I said okay we're
still having show as I was seeing all
this happen I could see that I wasn't
gonna be able to celebrate my birthday I
was born March 23rd that's it I knew
that the show was gonna get canceled and
as the show started canceling I said not
quickly show now my birthday show please
what happens they call me hey laughs
actor E has to let it go once the state
of California announced hey guys we're
shutting everybody down Jenna gather
more than ten people I got the call and
that was a cherry on top
but till my manager okay so when can we
get back up and running is it you don't
that's it everything is done everything
is closed now because we're stuck in the
house and because you know we're going a
little stir-crazy
I started to realize that this is
affording me the perfect opportunity to
start a clothing line that I've always
wanted to do right now it's just a
t-shirt business but I do hope to expand
out so I created this t-shirt I've
created some other t-shirts which are
hella dope at least I think so and I've
definitely taken the time to make sure
that I stay productive because I can get
a little I think we can all get a little
stir-crazy when we're stuck in the house
we had to think fast and I luckily got a
job teaching English online to Chinese
students this has been great because one
I teach in my pajamas how cool is that
and my my parents and my students have
been so supportive so in the meantime my
source of income
has been skirt put on the backburner and
all I have been doing is promoting
artwork but different kinds of artwork
not just tattoos I've been promoting my
paintings I've been doing different
kinds of paintings I also paint custom
shoes these are the the space jams you
know some some I'm just staying busy
these are some boots that I customized
and this is what I'm trying to you know
promote biggest things that I've
approached this quarantine with is how
to use my skill set and whether it's
just as a gift to somebody but also as
an additional income because truly
anything really helps right now so I've
been I've been baking bread for my
neighbors who have been tipping me which
makes me feel great one of the things is
making birthday cupcakes and cakes for
people at home because normally you
would just like run to the store and get
a cake and that's not as accessible or
convenient anymore and so I put up a
flier in our elevator and I was like hey
is anybody having a birthday or they
just want a cake you know let me know as
a comic we are our own producers our own
bosses okay so it's not like I can go to
somebody else and say hey can I have an
employment no I'm a contractor but I
have other resources for example I'm
knowledgeable OSHA rules rules so what I
started doing is I reached out to a
company that does safety meanings
company I'm working with its bridge
safety consulting what they do is
basically engage their audience
basically the workforce in a funny
comedic way and that's where I come in
that's where bridge said this is awesome
I want to do safety with a smile times
are tough and if you're a comedian can
you help me deliver these safety
messages these certain things that I
knew how to do it was then so now I
started because I need these safety
meetings through this video chat and
with video chat or webcams now we're
able to deliver these mess
these are just some of the things that I
had to do to basically stay up slow
I've been working with online platforms
such as up work and a lot of freelance
applications in order to get really
small projects here and there just to
get by I understand many people are
struggling through this really hard time
and the biggest challenge for me was
staying positive turning on the news and
watching the news every day has been a
little bit draining mentally for for us
as a family and I think it's really
important that we stay positive for
ourselves and for everybody around us
guys best thing you do is keep yourself
busy do all the things that you never
want to do never have time to do and I
know because I never had time to do
these things and that includes being
with your family bond with your
daughters I'm
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]